la célèbre boisson jauneeple a son
nouveau salon le weekend dernier se
tenait le premier versaill whisky vibes
dans la cité royale initiation à la
dégustation ou mastercl auprès d'experts
de ce spiritueux au tour de whisky du
monde 24 distileries étaient présentes
au Palais des Congrès de Versailles
objectif permettre aux amateurs
d'affiner leur palais pour distinguer
chaque subtilité du produit un achat
d'une bouteille de whisky ça peut aller
de 50 à beaucoup beaucoup plus cher
c'est toujours un certain risque on a
jamais goûté de d'arriver chez soi ou de
l'offrir à quelqu'un et de se dire bon
bah finalement dommage j'aime pas
vraiment donc c'est une bouteille qui
dure longtemps qui reste longtemps et
tant qu'elle est pas fini on ose pas
trop s'en racheter une autre découvrir
de nouveaux spiritueux et mieux
comprendre l'histoire de chaque maison
maltage fermentation et vieillissement
cette distillerie artisanale anglaise
proche d'Oxford démontrait son
savoir-faire une production locale de la
récolte du grain jusqu'à l'embouteillage
savoir que le marché français c'est
vraiment un marché passionné de on
aurait tendance de dire de de de geek de
G c'est pointu dans le milieu qui sont
éclairés avertis qui sont curieux qui
cherchent donc à découvrir des
nouveautés et donc pour une disie comme
la mienne qui est relativement
catégorisé comme jeune ça fait une
dizaine d'années qu'on existe c'est très
important je suis pas forcément un très
grand connaisseur de whisky mais j'aime
bien ça et j'avais envie de voilà
découvrir un peu des whisky très
différents de découvrir des nouvelles
choses et voilà de d'approfondir un peu
mes connaissances du whisky une
célébration de cette eau de vie
accompagnée de Music Live pour allier
plaisir du palais et des oreilles ce
premier salon à Versailles a réuni 500
amateurs attaché à ce breuage la France
est le premier pays consommateur de
whisky écossais au
monde